what are you it's just a little girl
sitting in a corner going I smell like
be I smell like be there's no context so
it's amazing
just like life is that we are are you
okay I just woke up alright no you
didn't what oh sorry I almost restarted
my computer accident because it asked me
I thought I'd do an update which I don't
what kind of update I don't know
something stupid I don't need stupid
like shopping for wine or the grocery
store when your kid is just dying on
wingtok I mean I mean that's pretty
stupid shopping for wine is pretty
stupid unless you're doing it with wink
wink is a service that you shop for can
do your palate profile quiz they
determine what kind of wine you like
scientifically and then they send it to
your door that's it try wink calm sauce
gonna Julian you check it out right now
you get 20 bucks off and they'll cover
the shipping and then you don't have to
get wine and you have wine it's great
try ring Thompson join me don't don't
sit here and read this this is the
podcast I have been preoccupied with
other things that Jenna decided to write
this whole thing so I'm I literally have
no idea what's happening this episode
even right now well you know so since
Julian was handling some things today
and a lot has just been a lot going on
in general I was like okay you gonna
leave me up tomorrow
devices to do the podcast so guess what
we gonna do dad N&A it's time for Jerry
things Wikipedia specifically about I'm
sorry
secret societies secret societies let's
do this one about secret societies sorry
I move to my voice deep so I could say
secret societies actually personal you
can't hear but I accept your apology
hopefully you guys are you're still work
I'm sorry okay with great sound boards
come great responsibility
do you want to hear about some secret
societies doing yeahyou does it just
works can you explain what's happening
yeah so like I feel like in the past
we've talked about some of these on the
podcast like the Illuminati the
Rosicrucians stuff like that like old
the old ancient sort of secret societies
that are still around in some capacity
today and like the Illuminati yeah
literally just said the Illuminati
[Laughter]
everything trying to keep up here okay
but then like there's only so many the
date back like that long that are still
around in some capacity so then I was
like well the other thing that I'm
interested in is not like the worst
cults that's ever existed because those
are kind of all over the place and like
you can read about those but like what
cults still exists now can you why are
you looking at me like that like what
like what cults are still in place right
now that people might not know about
yeah got it
so first we're gonna talk about the
origins and stuff about some of the
secret societies because I like I've
looked at a lot of conspiracy theories
that deal with some of these things but
I guess I didn't really know the true
origins of them and what they are so it
was interesting to do so are you ready
I'm ready and then one of them I just
threw in because it's one of my
favorites but whatever let's start off
with the Illuminati [ __ ]
starting off heavy I like it all right I
didn't know any of this and then I read
this and I was like it kind of blew me
away a little bit so Julian do you know
what the Illuminati is yes and no it's
like hard to I don't really know I mean
I know that it's this secret society
with all these famous people in it too I
don't even know what their end goal is
or their mission is but yeah that's
that's about are you ready for the
actual history of the Illuminati yeah
according to Wikipedia right yeah so
some some organizations that claim to
the Illuminati or whatever are
fictitious but the original the original
is referring to the Bavarian Illuminati
which was founded on May 1st 1776 by
Adam Weishaupt poped who's a professor
of Canon Law and practical philosophy at
the University of Ingolstadt
I don't remember what country we gained
independence that year what yeah we did
we did didn't as good you um let me look
it up University of Ingolstadt
it's what why are you laughing
I just thought of a word it's a it's in
Bavaria where's that it's a country
Julian
Oh Germany okay I was gonna say that
sounds German but I didn't know if that
sunrise I was gonna say that sounds like
sort of German so I was gonna say that
sounds German oh my god I returned this
what are you doing don't I don't like
that I can't use my computer are you
doing that subscribe before you is
officially the free state of Bavaria is
a landlocked federal state of Germany
okay okay anyways okay he was a
professor of Canon Law and practical
philosophy at the University of
Ingolstadt he was the only non clerical
professor at an institution run by
Jesuits and their power had been
dissolved within the university in 1773
but they still had a lot of control and
they constantly tried to discredit any
non clerical staff so you're like you're
basically teaching at this religious
school and although they don't actually
have any power at the school anymore
they still sort of find their way to
control what's being taught what's being
talked about and any of the
non-religious professors were sort of
ostracized for that yeah especially any
course material that was considered
liberal or Protestant and so he got
pretty annoyed at all of that and became
deeply antic
and wanted to spread the ideals of the
Enlightenment through some sort of
secret society of like-minded
individuals
he found the the Freemasonry to be
expensive and not open to his ideas so
he founded his own Society
original name was wonder perfect the
Bilson and the covenant of
perfectibility and it wasn't until 1778
that the order became the order of the
Illuminati after he had seriously
considered calling it the B order I feel
like what a missed opportunity
the Illuminati could have been called
the B order they would have had a
built-in mascot okay so they basically
sought after rich docile willing to
learn men aged 18 to 30 that were
otherwise interested in joining the
Freemasons so he would sort of poach
them over to the Illuminati instead and
the Freemasons is one of the groups that
I'll go through and describe to by 1784
across several countries are around 650
verifiable members they did not get
along with the Rosicrucians they tousled
like some hot boys they would not fans
of each other they saw themselves as
direct competition and they knew they
needed these young hot members for them
you know what I'm saying and I'll also
talk about the rest of Christians to the
Society's goals were to oppose
superstition obscurantism or whatever
that word is but basically like they
didn't want the truth being blocked from
them for any sort of religious reason or
political reason they wanted free and
open information and truth without it
being bogged down by religion if that
makes sense
that's what they wanted for society or
for society and for them yeah they
didn't want any religious influence over
public life and they also were against
abuses of state power they eventually
declined because some of the the people
like the lower ranking members in their
group made some dangerous political
boasts of power and criticism of the
monarchy and it
as a secret artists existence to become
common knowledge along with the names of
many of the important members which now
you've lost a lot of your power because
everyone knows who's in your group this
is terrible and a lot of them were like
in the government and things like that
so they sort of got you know the lid
blown off of them
they were outlawed along with the
Freemasons and other secret societies by
a very ruler Charles Theodore with the
encouragement of the Catholic Church so
it was like the the government and the
Catholic Church basically was like look
you guys are plotting to sort of like
maybe not overthrow the government but
like directly contradict what we're
doing so you guys can get the [ __ ] out
they were claimed to be continued
continuing running underground and some
critics say that they were responsible
for the French Revolution it's not
confirmed - can't confirm it and several
recent and present-day fraternal
organizations claimed to be descended
from the original primary and Illuminati
and openly used the name Illuminati some
of these groups use a variation of the
name the Illuminati order while others
such as the Ordo Templi Orientis have
Illuminati as a level within their
organizations hierarchy however there is
no evidence that these present-day
groups have amassed significant
political power or influence and most
rather than trying to remain secret
promote unsubstantiated links to the
Bavarian Illuminati as a means of
attracting membership so according to
Wikipedia and the history of the a true
original Illuminati is no such like
long-running group that's trying to
control the media or trying to control
your thoughts or anything like that
that's all a modern-day construct of the
Illuminati and if whoever whatever
actual organization if it exists that
claims to be the Illuminati has
absolutely no connection to the original
Illuminati interesting so what they're
complete are they currently doing what
it's who currently Illuminati if that's
not they're the original ones dissolved
it's gone so it's just it many many
years ago yeah like seventeen hundreds
so today's society's idea of the
illumine
is all fake according to Wikipedia it's
just made up it's interesting I mean
just kind of hit a dead end there I
don't know what do you mean I just think
it's crazy that like we have this
modern-day construct of what the
Illuminati is but it's actually not
based on anything that happened in
history at all like I feel like I
remember the take off like online of it
being like Illuminati and it started
turning into a meme and a joke let's
just entertain the fact sorry well then
you see all these conspiracy theories
that this is a group of people that are
trying to control your mind through
music and pop and culture and that kind
of thing when in reality the the
original organization had nothing to do
with any of that they just didn't want
religion like infiltrating their life
and ability to like do science or study
the subjects that they wanted to and
they were trying to break away from
their government being so heavily
influenced by Catholicism and Jesuits or
whatever initially they didn't have much
problem with government itself they just
had problems when church and state were
running yeah they wanted freedom to
study what they wanted to study so my
thing is that was advocate here but if
if we live in a world where the
Illuminati quote-unquote is a thing
where we're the secret societies
actually what you know super you know
deep into this operation many many years
of controlling people's minds with music
to do whatever if it was you know like
all these people who we make memes about
being the Illuminati if they were all
really in it you think it'd be a little
harder to find information on than just
like googling it right well yeah I mean
that's that sort of adds to the whole
shroud of secrecy of the modern-day
Illuminati is that you can't find out in
any information or if it's like a
physical group or if they because some
of these groups like like the Illuminati
or the Rosicrucians - the Freemasons
like you can see them going to have a
meeting or like you know they you know
that they physically gather with each
other in today's day and age with the
internet we know that people don't
physically need to
meet in order to have some sort of
course so maybe you wouldn't see them
and that sort of adds again to the this
mysterious group of people who are they
what are they doing what are they
working on like what is it's all about
but in in like fact basis they have no
connection to the original Illuminati
and that's not what the Illuminati was
even formed to do it's interesting right
yeah I think that answer and what you
found is way more interesting and if you
order like I've googled it and been like
the Illuminati calm really like that
that is more interesting it makes me
think about what yeah possibilities are
I feel like this is such a subtle burn
in here is that it's today's Illuminati
instead of trying to be secret they
actively use that name to like gain
membership or people to participate in
whatever they're doing as a means of
attracting membership like it wasn't an
ashamed awesome video where he like went
on that website it was like join the
Illuminati like I don't remember him
paying money in that video but it was
like sign up for an email newsletter and
like [ __ ] like that but I mean we both
know that there is things to be gained
from even making an email list of people
sell them [ __ ] in the future yeah so I
mean that's maybe they're not taking
membership fees but they now have a
database of people that are interested
in being a part of the Illuminati that
they can then take money from in the
future to keep their Illuminati running
mhm but the construct of the Illuminati
apparently is completely made up
probably by people on the internet it's
a goofy it's a goofy idea why also I
think it's it's fun to entertain the
idea of like messaging in in movies and
in music music and that kind of thing
but like it might not be a centralized
sort of well organized organization yeah
there might be a lot of mixed messages
going on within the society that a lot
of people misconstrue and and do do
different things different ways in their
own attempt to try to spread the message
well honestly if I was a pop star and I
was like people thinking part of the
Illuminati like dangled me off set out
in a giant triangle like think I'm part
of the Illuminati it's [ __ ] graves
people talking
sure does well and also imagine if you
were just like all the like satanic
imagery and stuff that I feel like pop
stars throw in there and then people
like Illuminati it's a messaging it's
satanic
imagine if you like in a world where you
did get I don't know brought into the
Illuminati at one point there wasn't
this big meeting and everyone wore hoods
and you were in the middle of the woods
and whatever and it was the official
Illuminati meeting it's like Jay Z's
there and they're all just you know
hanging out mm-hmm and they give some
sort of really vague like this is what
we have to do and you are now
responsible here's our symbol whatever
and then they'd vanish and then that
maybe that was all maybe it was real
maybe was a scam regardless if the if no
follow up ever was made on behalf of the
people who ran that event maybe the
people who were there at first were like
hey let's just keep it going and let's
let's just continue just to be like you
said let's to keep wearing the brand to
get people talking about it mm-hmm you
seem so unimpressed by that theory yeah
I don't know I just think that maybe
that that there was one piece of
tangible evidence that they experienced
and then it's gone but they were like
hey let's hold onto this because it's
cool mm-hmm yeah yeah but it has no
basis in history of it being the
original Illuminati which is Rhett why
are you looking at me like that are you
no sure yeah I just told you it's not
even a real thing they were disbanded in
Europe and the 1700s okay let's move on
Julian what the hell what are you doing
I think you might be in ok I just told
you it I know but that's what someone
who's in the illumina I would say sorry
do you want to go through the rest of
these or you want to just argue about
whether or not I'm in the Illuminati
you're good I feel like I've always had
an understanding of what the Freemasons
are but I've never actually read their
Wikipedia page or like information on
them and how they started and who they
are have you know
I mean I yeah okay because I always sort
of likened them to like the Illuminati
or something where it's like this very
secret group of people that you know do
[ __ ] yeah but apparently they don't
so according to Wikipedia it's basically
the world's oldest and largest
fraternity since the middle of the 19th
century Masonic historians have sought
the origins of the movement in a series
of similar documents known as the old
charges dating from the red Jesus poem
in 1425 to the beginning of the 18th
century it began in medieval Europe as a
guild for stonemasons but lived on as a
social organization that's when they
begin to see people joining these things
called lodges which is like a building
in local areas where people go to have
Freemason meetings called lodges when
they where they go they learn sort of
the history of the craft the oaths on
fidelity that you need to take in order
to join and in the 15th century there
begins to be evidence of ceremonial
regalia and like sort of rituals and
that kind of thing but I'll still
private also private yeah there's no
clear mechanism by which these local
trade organizations became today's
Masonic lodges but the earliest rituals
and passwords known are the same as the
passwords used later and in different
areas that did not practice a physical
craft so you're not seeing essentially
like a knockoff 2k version of Mason and
Freemasons they're still using all the
same traditional things as the actual
stone masons do they're just popping up
in different areas so they are direct
you know descendants right now the of
true Freemasons direct but modern
descendants yes because modern they
stopped using the physical craft of
masonry as a part of their ritual they
kept the name in the local correct yeah
the earliest known Lodge in America was
in Pennsylvania and then after the
American Revolution independent US Grand
Lodge is developed within each state
people that were freemasons include
George Washington Ben Franklin Winston
Churchill Mozart Davy Crockett Franklin
Roosevelt Harry Houdini Gerald Ford
Henry Ford John Wayne like the list goes
on and on and on
and if you want to be a freemason you
basically go to a lodge you then
demonstrate a good character and a
belief in some sort of Supreme Being
it's almost all men for the most part
you think and then they vote to either
accept you or not and then there's three
degrees that you have to go through and
once you earn your third degree which is
also apparently where that saying comes
from like to the third degree
that's from masonry you can join any
other Masonic offshoots they built 22
children's hospitals where patients
don't have to pay a cent and they donate
two million dollars to charity every
single day the Catholic Church along
with flip what they donate two million
dollars to charity every day yeah
according to Wikipedia that is so much
money yeah how do they get all that
money I don't know every day every day
god but like unlike some of the others
like I'm not I'm not out here trying to
call Scientology is secret society or a
cult or whatever it's I'm not trying to
bash anything it scares the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of me but like an organization like
that you'll see them these people being
unbelievably rich and the church has so
much money and that kind of thing the
Freemasons tend to take a lot of their
money and use it towards charitable
things like maybe a church like a
Catholic Church or like a sample would
do they're doing community service
basically yeah yeah yeah so there were
secret society that likes to do charity
which is not common apparently no it
could be yeah yeah so my question is
like if their secret society under what
like business name or company do they
make these donations or like how do
people monitor how much they're donating
or how do they legitimize or verify any
of that I don't know the size of your
secret society I mean but that's the
thing though is that the for the
Freemasons they're not considered a
secret society because people know who
they are I guess my question is like
legally what is the secret society yeah
I mean like like does the secret society
the the Illuminati is a secret society
but like I
yeah Freemasons Rosicrucians like these
people identify with these screws
not a secret society I guess by what
you're trying to define it is but the
inner workings of it are secret to the
public kind of inner workings are secret
then the name doesn't secret the fact
that they exist is not a secret all
right got it whereas if you're talking
about the modern-day Illuminati you
would say that that's a secret society
because the even just the presence of it
or existence of it is a secret hmm right
yeah they donate two million dollars to
charity every single day according to
Wikipedia the Catholic Church along with
many other religions were opposed to
Freemasonry because they teach a
naturalistic day istic religion which is
in conflict with a lot of religions and
the 1917 code of canon law explicitly
declared that joining Freemasonry
entailed automatic excommunication and
banned books favoring Freemasonry so you
can get kicked out of the Catholic
Church if you also wanted to join a
Freemasonry Society historians estimate
about 80,000 to 200,000 Freemasons were
killed under Nazi regime Masonic
concentration camp inmates are
classified as political prisoners and
more an inverted red triangle Hitler
believed Freemasons had to come to Jews
conspiring against Germany today it has
in the u.s. that has 1.3 million members
and in 1959 it had about 4 million so it
is getting smaller
Wow that's interesting yeah and it's
only based like us know it's started in
Europe and it's in the u.s. there's one
by three members correct merica members
according to Wikipedia interesting they
have that it's like a triangle with like
that yeah they have like a compass and
not to come yeah that kind of thing yeah
and I mean the the conspiracy theories
about Freemasons are fantastic about the
way that they build buildings and things
like that you know when you see all
those like aerial map conspiracy
theories about the way the Washington DC
is shaped and how its shaped like you
know Masonic symbols and like on the
dollar builders Masonic symbols and all
of this and we had that podcast talking
about Francis Bacon and he was more
closely associated I think with the
Rosicrucians maybe but also free me
and that he was actually this if you
haven't seen that podcast is gonna sound
like a crazy mess but it's actually one
of my favorite conspiracy theories that
Francis Bacon was actually William
Shakespeare and actually wrote all of
his works to sort of bring language and
culture to Europe so they could
inevitably take over North America and
rebuild it as a new society with
education and language and everything
being unified there's really if you
wanna think it's a conspiracy there's
part for if you wanted to listen to that
I think that's the one we did that on
yeah and again it's sort of like it's
it's a really fun theory I think that
there's a lot of really good cool stuff
in there even if you don't think that's
what happened but he's basically in that
theory as well it was like all of the
Masonic symbols that were built in the
United States were sort of from that
same hmm you know yeah school of thought
that's interesting they wanted to build
the United States is this like Masonic
sort of utopia man does it feel like
utopia these days
really oh speaking of utopia you're
talking about the other day if we could
find enough people who had enough pull
in the industry we could relaunch utopia
2.0 with the original cast just add a
couple twists here and there and get
that thing back on TV or honestly
[ __ ] TV get that thing on the air I just
want to rewatch it again let's make that
a new Netflix original yeah I really
wanna watch it I don't know but I know
that that show started in like another
country at some European country it was
like a big deal where where it started
and then that this was the American
version of it I wish we defined the
original like Danish or something
version of the show the we could this
successful version so we could watch it
successful like so in this situation so
if we could find it with English
subtitles so in this situation this is
like the office but where the UK version
ran the other the others are just
killing it yeah like the
but it started there it didn't start
here
I guess that's that's a difference we
were the ripoff but we also failed okay
you ready for the next one yeah so there
this is probably one of my favorite
secret societies why did you just do
that what you had it no I saluted that
was my secret
it's the Rosicrucians between 16 14 and
16 says just wanted to first read
because we talked about secret societies
in order for something to be considered
a secret society they have activities
events inter functioning or memberships
that are concealed from non-members the
society may or may not attempt to
conceal its existence the term usually
excludes covert groups such as
intelligence agencies or guerrilla
insurgencies that hide their activities
and memberships but maintain a public
presence the exact qualifications for
labeling a group a secret society are
disputed but definitions generally rely
on the degree to which the organization
insists on secrecy and might involve the
retention and transmission of secret
knowledge the denial about membership
our knowledge of the group the creation
of personal bonds between members of the
organization and the use of secret rites
or rituals which solidify members in the
group Wow that sounds exactly the
sequence ideas yeah well I mean I just
like like what I like and what I think
draws a lot of people to secret
societies is like speculating about what
these rituals and things that they do
are are they you know a lot of people
when they hear the word ritual they
automatically are like this is satanic
this is this has got to be bad and I
feel like even the like these are some
of the more famous some of the more
popular ones but there are secret
societies that just do like the most
horrible things you can probably so many
of them that you could never even know
like right and I feel like a lot of the
cults like the more famous cults that
you know although not all but like a lot
of the really terrible ones that just do
unthinkable unspeakable things they get
taken down by the government so I don't
know they've been called cults but I
imagine a lot of them could probably be
labeled secret societies as well because
there's some [ __ ] dark [ __ ] okay
anyways the Rosicrucians between sixteen
fourteen and sixteen seventeen three
anonymous manifestos were published see
this is like I'm already here like I
mean if he is secret [ __ ] okay
first in Germany and later through
Europe they were the fama fraternity
tightest are see the fame of the
Brotherhood the confession of the
Brotherhood and the chemical wedding of
Christian Rosa cross they were and are
not taken literally by many but they're
regarded as either hoaxes or allegorical
statements the fame of the Brotherhood
presents the legend of a German doctor
and mystic philosopher referred to as
father brother later identified in a
Christian ethic Christian Rosen
Rosenkreuz or Rose cross the year
thirteen seventy eight is presented as
being the birth year of our Christian
father and it is stated that he lived a
hundred and six years after studying in
the Middle East under various masters he
was unable to spread the knowledge he
had acquired two prominent European
scientists and philosophers so instead
he gathered a small circle of friends
and disciples and founded the
Rosicrucian order around 1407 the writer
also claimed the brotherhood possessed a
book that resembled the works of
Paracelsus I think I don't know if I'm
saying that wrong but he's credited as
being the father of toxicology he was a
physician Alchemist and astronomer so
like again back to the definition of a
secret society they're in possession of
some secret knowledge or some secret
thing or that they're trying to you know
some knowledge that they're protecting
and or message that they're carrying
whatever I feel like the Rosicrucians
are there they're a good secret society
you know they feel like that got mad
secrets anyway the literature announced
them as moral and religious reformers
they use the techniques of chemistry
alchemy and the sciences generally as
media through which to publicize their
opinions and beliefs in the early 17th
century the manifestos caused excitement
throughout Europe by declaring the
existence of a secret Brotherhood of
alchemists and sages who were preparing
to transform the arts sciences
and political and intellectual landscape
of Europe wars of politics and religious
and religion ravaged the continent so
like imagine now or like just imagine
then so it's just like war and religion
and politics is just all over the place
like terrible everything sucks and then
you just have these brilliant people
that are like hey man anybody want to do
some [ __ ] science with me over here
it's not telling you what we're doing
cuz they'll get in trouble with the
government or with the Pope or whatever
the hell so they're like anybody wanna
do some [ __ ] science come join my club
if we Tuesday rocks ecology come over no
alchemy and chemistry and stuff like
that astronomy mmm this is stone for
teenagers yeah yeah I'd be like hell
yeah boy I want to be in the
Rosicrucians you feel me dog okay during
frozen cruises lifetime the order was
said to consist of no more than eight
members each a doctor and a sworn
bachelor each member under took an oath
to heal the sick
but without payment to maintain a secret
fellowship and to find replacement for
himself before he died three generations
had supposedly passed between 1500 and
1600 a time when scientific
philosophical and religious freedom had
grown so that the public might benefit
from the Rosicrucians knowledge so they
were now seeking good men their writings
point towards a symbolic and spiritual
alchemy rather than an operative one in
combination of direct and veiled styles
these writings conveyed the nine stages
of the involve evolutive transmutation
of the threefold body of the human being
the threefold soul and the threefold
spirit among other esoteric knowledge
related to the path of initiation
so like unlike what's said about
Freemasonry the Rosicrucians they do
seem to have some element of like
religion almost in their okay you know
what I mean because that is like its
kind of yeah what like that's that's
kind of the basis of how it began so so
long ago now his religion no well I mean
some of it was a like they're directly
conflicting
with the religion that's you know all
around them all the time and also
governing them it's their answer to that
it's there like version we believe this
instead okay but I mean the Freemasons I
think started before the Rosicrucians so
it's not like it started so early okay
fair enough
okay according to Masonic writers the
order of the rose cross is expounded in
major Christian literary work that
molded the subsequent spiritual beliefs
of Western civilization the Divine
Comedy by Dante Alighieri just
interesting they explained it like all
over the place and then to this day
there's literally like a full page of
organizations that generally speak of a
lineal descent from earlier branches in
England France Egypt and other countries
some groups speak of spiritual
affiliation and some are still operating
some have dissolved but the Rosicrucians
are all over the place in different
forms and different branches interesting
right yeah I feel like I don't know any
Rosicrucians reliefs did they tell you
if they were I don't know I guess I
should ask what I wonder how many
advances in the science world were made
by Rosicrucians I don't know I don't
know the answer to that but I mean the
the stuff about Francis Bacon in the
Rosicrucians and the Freemasons is
fascinating to me but it's pretty cool I
didn't know the history of them so I
thought that was really cool so far if
you had to pick he would be Rosicrucians
maybe freemasons what do you mean which
one would you pick to be in right now
honestly probably freemasons cuz it
doesn't like I'm a little scared of any
sort of religious stuff I'll pick the
dead Illuminati hmm the one that has
nothing to do with what people think
yeah no I just like the more secretive
of a society the more I'm intrigued in
it but I'm not interested in any of this
do any of them gather around the fire
and drink mysterious liquids tureen I
see where you're going and I'm Julianne
curious liquid I caught you you big gosh
right link calm
if you're young society you need wine
Julian you don't have time because
you're doing secret society stuff go to
try wing calm guys you just enter your
profile choices then you get your pal
profile all set and then they send you
want based on your own tastes and
they'll send you the good stuff the
stuff that you'll never find for
yourself in the store because you're
gonna be walking up you're gonna be
walking them
you walking down the aisle in the store
why my line Bob I'm late for my
Rosicrucians you know all these class I
grabbed one runs back and then you have
the bad one and that no one's happy you
get kicked out of your secret society
your whole life is it's all because you
could have just gone on to try wink calm
so I said enjoyin get twenty bucks off
your first order they'll cover the
shipping guys is a really nice thing
having wine shipped to your door and not
just any one wine that's specifically
tailored to you and your palate
so try wink guys go to try ring talk on
sauce Jen and Jillian or click the link
in our description and you will not be
disappointed the wine is delicious
okay here's something else
so I'd say that those are like probably
the more well-known secret societies and
at least in the United States and from
my favorite ones along with the Knights
Templar which I didn't put in this one
but we can talk about that some other
time maybe but they're they're like so
late but that's Templar yeah I feel like
there's you can't watch a history show
channel show without being like the
Knights Templar it's a Templar cross and
you're like oh damn they'd really be
[ __ ] oh here you go
okay so anyways let's move on to some
what why are you laughing at me I but
okay because I love this stuff no no no
alright well yeah but also I might
question about do they sit around the
fire and drink liquids while it was a
brilliant segue to our sponsor this week
of try wink calm it was also a genuine
question and thought like you always
think of secret societies having these
really creepy like meetings
and there what are they drinking and why
are they wearing what their work like
that's that's the stuff right stop it
I'm just curious all right let's listen
to some quiet yeah we need some music
music alright are you ready is that too
loud or no no I can't hear these are
known cults that still exist - I'm
scared
are you ready cuz like I said all of the
ones that are doing like there's so many
terrible cults that have done like of
course child abuse just the worst [ __ ] a
lot of those have been shut down
obviously because that's [ __ ] mass
suicides yes
mass suicides okay the first one is
called the Brethren this is actually
kind of funny to start off there also
known as the body of Christ and garbage
eaters brethren are an apocalyptic
offshoot of the 70s Jesus movement and
they they give up all of their worldly
possessions and earthly pleasures to
purify themselves for the coming of the
end of the world
brethren members essentially just live
on the street just wherever they do odd
jobs to survive they eat trash avoid
bathing and medical treatment and then
whatever money they do make they give to
the group okay they also forbid dancing
and laughing until the return of Jesus
no laughing no laughing what about the
fact that you're eating garbage every
day that's [ __ ] funny and durable bar
members from communicating with family
and forbid opposite sex contact oh don't
touch doesn't say anything about sex
Group founder Jim Roberts died in
December 2015
leaving the future of the secretive cult
unclear so why are they following the
trash eating rules they can go get
mcdonalds now
they don't need to be eating trash Jimmy
they're still people that are still
doing it they still believe it
no Jim died you here we can do whatever
we want I can talk to you even though
you ago
no laughing where's that garbage I'm
hungry no dancing until Jesus on the hot
plate of garbage I want to eat my
garbage with my garbage I found a fork
I'd like to eat this piece of garbage
with a fork from the garbage I feel like
sushi today let's go to the back alley
of the sushi restaurant garbage that's a
real cult that exists though called the
brethren brethren or the Brethren read
the rim so bread rather bread mint bread
the raiment okay are you ready for the
next one or do you want to keep calling
them the breath with it maybe four
button it okay
this next one this one's like creepy
okay it's called Congregation for the
light don't read over my shoulder I'm
gonna read it to you just sit back and
relax all right
it's a secret society and considered
occult base in Manhattan in a brownstone
on Murray Hill formed in the 1969 hatton
New York no chilly in Manhattan Idaho
yes Manhattan New York
okay followers claim to be followers
claim to be descendants from a master
Aryan race on Atlantis mm-hmm and that
humans once lived on the moon
homosexuality is banned they call it a
hangover from the Roman Empire corporal
punishment is encouraged they call
homosexuality a hangover from the Roman
Empire yeah corporal punishment is
encouraged and ma'am members atone for
bad karma from their past lives so they
believe in a lot of reincarnation that
kind of care young women are denied
higher education and are often married
off to older member in the group members
in the group so like for example there
was a story about a 19 year old girl
being married off to some 40
Goldmember in their group so that
happens so quick question the Brit what
are the name brethren this is not no
this is called Congregation for the
light or the light my question do they
live among in the city okay okay
so if I go if I go back to college I
won't find any of the girls there cuz
they're denied that yes they're denied
higher education many of them okay okay
but if I but if I encounter a 40 year
old man with a younger woman married
that could they could be proud of the
congregation for light yes
okay all right some male devotees have
gone under have undergone weapons
training to prepare for the end of the
world which they believe is coming soon
that's a lot of things like a lot of the
cults have this same doomsday theory
going on and a lot of them are like
polygamous culturally they just sort of
sleep with each other some of them are
spiritual cold some of them are like
terrorist groups that considered cults I
think by definition and some of these
okay anyways every Thursday evening
dozens of congregants line up on East
35th Street for the group's weekly
meeting there his leader Tom bear 73
years old preaches from the center of
the room members don't have religious
texts and aren't allowed to take notes
so he stands the issue there he stands
the middle of the room and just talks at
them and their knowledge to take note so
basically their entire religion which
they believe is a religion and their
tax-exempt because their religion is all
word of mouth it's based off of whatever
that guy has to say that day yes they're
tax exempt they have around 200 members
with congregations in Washington DC and
Atlanta as well as the New York City one
they believe that cancer and other
illnesses are the result of
at Karma nice real nice they try to
control parts of their life through
lucid dreaming or dreams so they like if
they're having trouble with something
they believe that if you have a lucid
dream about it and control it you can
fix parts of your life that's the most
relatable part about them I think they
can't miss meetings ever like not if
you're sick not for vacations on if
you're going somewhere like you can't
miss meetings ever if they don't take
role or take notes it sounds like no
one's even going to know he missed a
meeting sorry that's the fact
Morris Cates the chairman during the
1960s and 70s taught them that once the
world ended people would be reincarnated
on another planet called nay and they
would be one gender and have no stomachs
yeah they're symbols include owls like
the animal and X's children are taught
that they're not human until they're 13
years old and they're taught that if a
child dies before the age of 13 it's
because they committed suicide in a past
life holy [ __ ]
they get 10% of its funds from donations
and the rests to run the organization
they take from members when the members
die what yeah see that's some suspect
[ __ ] because that means there's
incentive for them to be killing off
members yeah they take money from their
states whoa it's groceries this one's
[ __ ] yeah where were New York City
Manhattan New York mm-hmm yeah if y'all
are ever on East 35th Street on a
Thursday night apparently they line up
and get ready to go have a meeting where
Tom just stands in the center of a room
and shouts at them how many members are
known to be in around 200 that's it
yeah so they gotta go go this sounds
very convincing they got those people
just lying in a Manhattan I'm taking
care of it they're gone Charlie what the
hell okay this next one is called Church
of God with signs following
that's the whole name yes they're better
known as snake handlers this fringe
Christian order takes an oft
misinterpreted passage of Mark and uses
it as a pretext for an incredibly
dangerous practice believing snakes are
a manifestation of demons believers pick
them up and raise them into the air even
allowing them to slow their all over
their bodies naturally this results in
the snakes getting upset and dozens of
snake handlers have died due to
poisonous bites it doesn't help that
they refuse medical treatment believing
that God will cast the poison out of
them based on almost entire it's based
almost entirely in the South though a
few sects are in Canada they also
practice a form of aesthetic holiness
shunning flamboyant dress and alcohol
practicing foot washing and speaking in
tongues local legislators have made
snake handling illegal for religious
purposes though these laws are rarely
enforced it's thought that there are
anywhere from a thousand to five
thousand members of the Church of God
with signs following divided into
autonomous sects around the south and
southeast
what is foot washing I think it's just
when you've washed your feet so like
they don't take showers they only just
it's like a ritual foot washing alright
that was that was the weirdest part of
that one of them yeah what about the
people that just died because they think
that God's gonna cast the poison out of
them I mean it's preemptive a little
pre-emptive
what it also that sounds like a bunch of
craziness there's about 5,000 members
and they live in the south of this
country where but it just says the south
it's big area where Julian I don't know
why don't you look it up alright alright
you ready for the next one yeah
alright this is called economic in car
Eckankar I don't know if I'm saying that
right it was founded in 1965 by Paul
Twitchell this nonprofit religion
bounced around to a few locations before
settling in suburban Minneapolis like
many other New Age religions
Eckankar is a grab-bag of mysticism
Eastern philosophy meditation and
made-up iconography members claimed to
have ancient roots going back tens of
thousands of years speak to each other
in an invented language and taken on new
names for themselves all of it is done
in the name of meditation where one
chance
who and separates their soul from their
body this is my favorite part are you
ready for this part despite being a
registered nonprofit the group the group
sells its founders materials for a hefty
profit and allegations have abounded
that virtually all of Twitchell's books
laying the foundation of economic
Eckankar are plagiarize plagiarize yes
my guy my guy dude he's like you know
what we're making our own Bible but hold
on I got be right back I gotta get it
they're gonna print some stuff out I'll
be back it costs $100 that's good chin
that's but that still exists there are
still people that practice Eckankar all
right this one is called children of God
David Berg who called himself himself
Moses David founded the organization
called the children of God in 1968 the
so called Jesus Movement was gathering
steam in the late 1960s and a lot of
disenfranchised hippies were ripe for
the picking Berg
started his first colony in Huntington
Beach California in similar colonies
soon sprung up in other states as well
as Europe and South America members were
required to relinquish relinquish all of
their worldly possessions and to the
commune and cut off all ties with their
families in the beginning so coltie yeah
members panhandled are busked turn money
to pay for food and other supplies but
as their numbers increased moses decided
they needed to earn dollars not spare
change so with many young attractive
women ready to do all his bidding the
answer was simple why not exploit the
world's oldest profession Berg called
this fundraising effort flirty fishing
as a result of his unique interpretation
of Matthew 4:17 flirty fishing was
officially banned by Berg in 1987 mainly
due to escalating AIDS epidemic
yeah children of God has changed its
name several times in recent years after
a barrage of bad publicity including
accusations of incest and other abuse
Berg passed away in 1994 in the group is
now known as the family international
it's led by Stephen Kelly that's somehow
a worse name who calls himself King
Peter family international weird and
creepy still around children of God all
right this is the last one
you ready this one is called the anthill
kids the majority of Canadians consider
Roche Roche burial there's I'm sorry I'm
gonna butcher the first area wrote
probably Roche Theriot to be one of
their country's most notorious criminals
but his devoted followers still call him
Moses in 1979 he set up a safe camp in
Burt River Ontario in preparation for
the apocalypse again let's see a theme
Cara charismatic and politically savvy
he attracted a small group of followers
that called themselves the anthill kids
all of whom were looking for a spiritual
salvation and pure existence the nine
female members were his concubines
were required to be subservient to the
male members of the set over 20 children
were born into the group in the ensuing
years many of whom were sired by Roch
the guy himself
yeah.but group earned money by selling
baked goods door-to-door because Moses
had officially registered his commune as
a church provincial officials were
unable to do much about the primitive
living conditions where the members were
subject to they could only ensure that
the children had warm clothing and
proper nutrition he had a drinking
problem a superiority complex and
demanded absolute obedience from his
followers such unquestioning submission
led to the death of one of his wives
when she allowed him to operate on her
stomach ailment another female follower
risked her risked his wrath when she
fled to a hospital after he chopped off
her forearm with a cleaver in a fit of
anger it was that act of brutality that
finally brought the authorities swooping
down on the anthill he was found guilty
of murder in 1993 and sentenced to 25
years in prison he was denied parole in
2002 but he has fathered three more
children during his years in jail as a
result of conjugal visits with some of
his remaining faithful few is he still
alive I think so yes what the [ __ ] yes
there's still people that follow him and
think that he's like what a psycho he
chopped up a girl's arm he operated yeah
of stomach it's about that what's the
name of that guy's religion again one
more time the anthill kids okay dude
so beyond not okay
that guy mm-hmm no wonder it's a secret
society
don't nobody gonna approve that don't
nobody goin people that no no no the
finest secret society it would be just
like about how I love eating massive
amounts of pasta Emily which is he pasta
together yeah we'd call it macaroni
Monday and it would be lit for real what
would your secret society because mine
would literally be about eating pasta
mine would be for people that like just
sing made-up songs to their animals
it'll be the most annoying secret
society it would be great I can find
people just like me and I would find
pasta just like mine you know who'd be
the first person to join my group my mom
yeah she does almost like my mom yeah
though is it Gordon Ramsay would be a
mess even society you like those secret
society foster yeah thing that the
history it was cool but I'm also
interested to see like what exists today
right now like if you walk down the
streets in New York you can see those
people well they're true
that's interesting the stuff on
Wikipedia is stuff you can find the
internet with tangible like information
about their current whereabouts or
whatever it's interesting hmm
what's also interesting is I'm just
gonna say over the next couple weeks I'm
gonna keep a close eye on that Jenna and
Julian podcast email just to see if any
of them reach out cuz we talked about
him hey what's up I'm a freemason how's
it going maybe they're looking to to
partner with us okay let's play hey
what's up you guys were sponsored by the
Freemasons this week also sponsored by
the Rosicrucians sign up today or never
ever be invited again still waiting for
the Illuminati to hit us up uh yeah that
was good thank you for looking those up
that's all really I just I mean I know
there's not a lot of like commentary
it's just kind of really interesting to
hear like storytelling really
but it's real yeah but it's real it's
also terrifying verifiable but I feel
like the the main thing that they all
have in common and like my mom grew up
sort of in that like era you know like
she was 20-something in the 70s and like
young teen in the 60s like yeah cults
were like a real fear like I feel like
she knew people that were like had been
in a cult at one point like when they're
young and like they all have the same
thing in common which is like they cut
off you from your family that's number
one
yeah and like any sort of outside
contact and it's likely distributed like
any sort of independence or power that
you might have had us at normal human
nothing I mean it's kind of like what
Scientology does in a way right like
it's it's pretty fun but yeah loved ones
yeah
terrifying that's not good he'll you see
you guys next week goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]